he went from sipping his pint to saying
goodbye to his wife he never hesitated
he knew huge face German bullets
you just did it
being brought some of it has definitely
had an impact
every time we get a call I think of what
it must felt like to deal with this fear
in the way he did just go back since my
great uncle I think it's gone to my
granddad's and then my dad and then me
which is a family position suppose I'm
making the difference what do you mean
by making a difference saving lives
my great uncle worked at the lifeboat
station when the news came they needed
the help of every available ship to get
those soldiers off the beach at Dunkirk
anyone who's not gonna be like a bit
scared when they go towards bombs and
guns and all sorts barrack and
adrenaline gets rid of that
very much get it you just got going
there you go do it when they go to the
beach the soldiers waded out
they did their best to stitch them up
for the journey home that spirit it runs
in the family
it's what makes us who we are
these days the world's not like it was
it's incredible what he did that's what
drives me to help and volunteer being in
a situation where I've been scared at
all not yeah